you
hi everyone is Gerry let's have a look
at a game from the USSR championship
1961 tournament a this was the first of
two championships that year on the white
end David Bronstein a player who
narrowly missed becoming world champion
in his 1951 match against bad Vinick
they were tied after 24 games but there
wasn't a playoff so bad Vinick retained
the title Bronstein's opponent in this
one FM Geller aggressive style loves the
sharp stuff and this has produced great
results for him he has positive scores
against four world champions Botvinnik
smee Slav Petrosian and Fischer the game
we're about to see it's a miniature a 20
mover in really one of the more esthetic
endings you'll see to a game so let's
dive in and see how it develops first of
all the opening an Enzo Indian defense
with a quick question thrown to the
bishop after just these five there are
two things to note one White's happy
about the bishop pair and black is happy
about inflicting some structural defect
on the White Queen side now of these two
holes the one that's sticking out to me
more is c4 as that is the one that's a
bit more accessible to the black pieces
so from here black Kings tucked away
white wants to do one better instead of
a pawn duo wants a trio black interferes
with this but at the same time allows
white to now under the pawns black is
slightly ahead here development wise the
race here or the big battle I should say
is over the e4 square
ideally white would like to be able to
get in e4 and then start kicking around
the black pieces gaining space so many
many moves are directed at the e4 square
Knight to e2 97 Knight f4 this is a
reliable square f4 dark square you don't
have to worry about a dark square Bishop
bothering you and from here c5 slightly
head in development is black so
welcoming some pawn exchanges there's
now a path for the Queen Bishop d3 now
typically when you're working with the
bishop pair you would shy away from
welcoming a bishop exchange but white
really wants to eliminate pieces that
are controlling this and at the same
time expedite the development kind of
catch up some development wise Bishop d3
does this you know there is a punch
thrown now at f5 so after a capture the
Queen is recapturing getting a new piece
out and one that is helping facilitate
efore now I'm drawing a lot of attention
I realized to the e4 square as we'll see
in this game this isn't the only plan y
can go forward with continuing rook e8
sensible enough both Kings are now
tucked away black rooks are both
contributing and from here rook b1 so
some pressure against b7 clearly this is
something black says well I just don't
care about my B pawn Queen a5 go ahead
and take b7 and this is what white does
now one of the better moves is to
immediately focus on this weak point c4
Knight b6 and circle in there but black
activates the Queen allows the b-pawn to
be captured and only then plays Knight
to b6 now this rook on b7 is a little
bit stuck doesn't have many options like
b7 s the only safe Square now this other
idea I was just referencing a moment ago
about efore that's not the only idea
well what is this other idea why can go
forward with and take note of the mind
this is the one thing I take note of the
minor pieces that are involved before
going forward with this next plan in the
game it's g4
notice the squares that are weakened to
squares that are weakened f3 and h3
they're both light squares
this move is played in a situation where
there certainly isn't a light square
bishop around for black this would be a
far more committal move the move g4 if
black had a light square bishop around
maybe just a bad move anyhow I just want
to give draw some attention to this the
idea with g4 give the knight a shove you
don't necessarily have to go establish a
pawn on e4 to give the knight a kick
here comes the jeep um now this move is
allowing black to hunt the rook the top
move here by black is to play c4 now
it's kind of it's a bit counterintuitive
to to play rook c8 and then a moment
later just kind of go here the rook is
kind of weird but you know the idea is
to cut the Queen off from defending a
six so that the black Queen could play
Queen a6 next and the rook is cooked
rick has to take the night and we would
enter this imbalance where yeah still
kind of tricky to assess the beginning
of the video I was referencing Geller as
an aggressive player I don't know that
this is really a situation he'd like to
be in you know for example the knight
could be given a kick and then you have
this kind of stuff it seems like white
is the one that's having all the fun so
I'm drawing attention to this because
yes you could you could go and pick up
the rook but does it really suit the
style of team black not really so what
do we have here h6 g5 requires a little
bit more work
h4 on board and we're not seeing this c4
move instead things are opening up this
is what you would expect a sharp player
Geller
to peel things open make sure the rook
on c8 this move here was justified or is
justified see file is now opened up this
capture is ignored by Bronstein g5 the
knight is under fire black doesn't do
anything about that
instead captures on e3 black is
overlooking a fantastic finish to this
game must have been a great surprise to
him after the capture on f6 rook takes
c3 and were one move out from resigned
time
what does Bronstein play here feel free
to pause the video okay this is actually
a checkmate in three
if you didn't find the checkmate in
three feel free to pause the video once
more here we go star move of the game
Queen of g6 what a great finish that's
right here is Queen takes pawn mate what
do you do about that the only way you
could stop Queen takes g7 is to take the
Queen and if you do check pick your
favourite Square does not matter Knight
takes here for me a very aesthetic mate
I'd say I love this configuration of the
knight pawn and rook for mate Geller
knew what was coming after Queen to g6
threw in the towel after just 20
completely overlooked this star move by
Bronstein anyhow as usual feel free to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below hope you enjoyed
it and maybe even took a thing or two
away that's all for now take care bye
you